good afternoon I'm ed conjurer from the
college of new jersey and i'm here to
talk about developing and implementing a
technology plan for educators i will go
over what we did at the college of new
jersey and our experiences over the last
12 years
I'm at conjurer I'm at the college of
new jersey and i'm here to talk about
developing and implementing a technology
plan for educators i have a subtitle for
it getting the horse to the trough is
sometimes easier than getting it to
drink okay and i think you'll understand
why as i talk my presentation i'll give
you a little bit of background about me
the college of new jersey my definition
of what a technology plan is the
importance of phasing it in and most of
my time my short time will be talking
about creating faculty technology
profiles which is what i did first
identifying key courses if you want to
go someplace you have to know where you
are so determining the status quo you
can't do it by yourself
so identifying key faculty that are
gonna help you pull something off and
then getting feedback into the loops so
that you can make improvements and using
students and employers and other faculty
to and then I'll end with where we are
and where we're going and then I don't
know if we'll have time for questions
I'm a pure mathematician by training
I've had a lot of programming experience
I actually did assembler I saw that
assembler yesterday and I cringed
because I hated it and some of you
probably have never heard of some of
these languages APL anybody hear of APL
a programming language yes uh-huh
and then I moved on forth I actually
co-wrote a textbook and forth Pascal
basic C C++ Mathematica I guess that's
the curse word I'm not allowed to say
here MATLAB and visual basic Java Python
so I programmed in a lot of languages my
first real exposure I used Mathematica
before I went to Rocky Mountain
Mathematica Stan Waggin who's here he's
giving a talk and he was great that was
back the 1999-2000 and I came back so
inspired I said boy I'm gonna get
everybody in my department to use
Mathematica in their courses
so first a little bit about the college
roughly 6600 undergrads there are some
grad programs but only a few we have
about 355 faculty we have schools of
science engineering business social
science humanities art music and nursing
my department has a lot of majors 300
majors believe it or not they're in 4
programs we have what I call pure math
but the pure math don't like to call it
that so they just call it math and we
have applied math we have statistics and
math education here's my definition of a
tech technology plan ok it's a working
document that's backed by consistent and
ongoing effort and is designed to help
infuse technologies such as Mathematica
but others also into classroom
instruction and guided student research
I see three key ingredients you have to
start with a set of competency
guidelines that you want to shoot to try
to achieve okay
you need to get a lot of help both
inside and outside and then you have to
have a driving force someone who's going
to keep it going and keep us all on task
all right now when I drafted the
technology guidelines I described three
levels and level one is just exposing
the students to technology with a focus
on visualization so you want to show
that technology can aid through
demonstration demonstrations are great
and doing complicated computations and
using it to solve complex math problems
but I want to note that for level one
the focus is not on assessment it's to
get the students turned on to use it in
level two you you embed it entirely into
the learning process and you start and
so students are taught how to use it
when they're studying in my case
mathematics and statistics and then it
becomes part of the assessment process
so you know you want to make sure they
understand it and it plays a part in
assigning them a final grade to
level three which is the ultimate as far
as I'm concerned the students are able
to apply technology to solve difficult
and possibly open-ended problems which I
do give to my students where there's not
necessarily a specific way to do it and
then they have to design algorithms and
implement the algorithms to produce a
working solution to the problem okay
outside help it helps if you have a Dean
he'll give you 1/4 hour to add to a
course so they confuse technology and
the old Dean did the new I was the Dean
before that and then one after that did
but the new one isn't quite as generous
ok he says if you want to do it again
you have to take it from one eye that
you got it in before it's nice to have
people at Wolfram and E door sets my
contact here he comes to campus
periodically and gives seminars to the
faculty and I wanted to get the
licensing agreements so that the stall
the students could download it and I
finally convinced my Dean to do that but
it was with Andy's help explaining the
benefits of it and yet you have to have
other faculty who are willing to help
you gather information and do
coordination and that's the toughest
part as as you'll see driving force
somebody you or somebody else has to be
willing to do it at our place it's me so
I'm the driving force that sort of
cracks the whip
now phasing in the process is very
important and my in between 2002 and
2004 I call this how not to start and
you might say well you know myself and
two other colleagues wrote an NSF grant
proposal and it was funded and the title
of it was introducing software tools
into linear algebra and principles of
math which is now called proof writing
through discrete math and how could that
be a horrible way to start well during
the I took the principles of math course
and my two colleagues took the linear
algebra so I developed all these
mathematical modules for this course and
there was a fourth hour the reason it
was somewhat it was good but it was a
disaster there were two of us teaching
the course me
logician or any logicians in there this
logician didn't have a cellphone
didn't use Excel hated technology right
so I'm teaching it and he's teaching it
and mice I'm covering ten chapters he's
covering eight chapters and in addition
to me covering ten chapters I have all
these mathematical knowledge of modules
that students have to work on the good
students loved it they were getting more
bang for the buck in the course but boy
talk about student feedback a lot of the
students were saying why do I have to do
all this extra work when I could have
taken the course with Professor X so you
have to be careful what you if you wish
for something you might get it all right
worse yet after being in academic
administration for over twenty years I
gave up the chair job and then the new
chair didn't care about technology at
all so between 2005 and 2009 nothing
happened and to make it even worse
I wasn't even teaching the course so the
people teaching the course rewrote
history all referenced the technology in
the course disappeared and I sneaked it
in when I teach it anyway but in 2010 I
wrote the first draft of the technology
guidelines which was more inclusive than
when I showed you but and in between 11
and 12 started a phase in level 1 and by
identifying courses and I'll talk about
that in a minute and then between 2013
continued level 1 started to bring in
level 2 and officially I would say level
3 started last spring but I was doing it
before that but since I was the only
well me and maybe one other person I
don't really count that but now I have
more people bought into doing level 3 ok
gathering information
I created the profile all my faculty
identified key courses I determined the
status quo pulled in the faculty that I
knew would be willing to help me and
then use the feedback so what did I do
as far
the faculty was concerned first I gave
him a survey the first question was do
you own a cell phone second question was
to use Excel to use word do you consider
yourself to be a novice an average user
or an expert next thing I asked them was
do you program if you program what
languages do you program and how many
programs have you written in the last
year and do you use it in your
instruction do you use it in your
research and if so how after I got all
that data the second thing I did was i
sat down with every one of them I had
the data but what I wanted to find out
who would buy in so I wanted to find out
who had apprehensions who had fears and
where was their lack of enthusiasm so
that I could target different faculty to
teach the courses that I thought would
in fact do the job okay as far as which
courses this is only a partial list but
calc a and B all the Wolfram
demonstration project I have written a
ton of stuff in Mathematica so that was
perfect for level one the linear algebra
came out of the grant we had developed
all the materials using both MATLAB and
Mathematica so we had both labs in both
of those for level two there was a
colleague who sat in on a course that I
developed the computational math class
and he became excited and so he teaches
calc C so he used the Wolfram
demonstration project and developed his
own materials so he bought into it I
always thought number theory was a
perfect course for the use of technology
and so we use one professor uses
Mathematica another one uses Python
that's fine you know as far as I'm
concerned and the OD e class there again
three professors one uses MATLAB one
uses Mathematica and the other one uses
both you know sometimes neither so it's
hard one to keep in line now as far as
level three officially last spring when
I taught the computational math class
that's definitely level three
the applied math Capstone's level 3 and
even in the pure math capstone they used
some technology so we have it going at
level 3 in those courses and the upper
level stat course is used it a lot too
so this as I said these are partial list
okay how do you disturb the terminus
status quo you do survey you collect
data and use the data I would when I
when when I picked the elementary stat
courses as the targeted level one
sequence of courses I surveyed all the
instructors both regular and adjunct
faculty because the course syllabus said
they were using technology but to my
surprise when I did the survey there was
only one instructor who was actually
using it and that was an adjunct
professor which made it even worse so I
went to the stat committee and I said
hey you know departments bought into
this we want technology in there you
need to do something about it and
they've since done it so all this that
courses now all use some type of
technology keep faculty I have a faculty
coordinator for calculating being the
job of the coordinator is to form a
repository of all the materials that
people are using put them in a place
where other people can use them and then
ask them questions at the end of each
semester you know you know how did you
use it and what do you think and were
there any shortfalls or things like that
I have a faculty coordinator for calc C
he's the guy who sat in my computational
math class and there are three people
teaching that course and two of them use
Mathematica exclusively the third one
uses it for demonstration but not at
level two so we're good there I have a
faculty coordinator for all the intro to
stat courses and I have a faculty corner
coordinator for number theory all right
so feedback we have a Student Advisory
Board we meet with them and we get their
feedback what you know not just about
technology about everything what do you
think about this does it
work our senior exit survey we dis let
me put questions in there to ask them
their reactions about the technology
they've seen was it useful we discovered
from our senior survey that the we've
the first course that we refuse back I
don't know how many we we added a
correlate requirement of a computer
programming course that's offered by the
computer science department what we
learned from the student feedback was
the course we we picked really was
terrible as far as preparing them for
what we wanted them to know so we
switched courses and we're currently
looking at that course because it's the
first course that the computer science
majors take but the assign I looked at
all the assignments the assignments they
give are not the computational kinds of
things that we want our math majors to
see they're focusing more on writing
games and with the object-oriented part
of the the language as opposed to you
know doing a math type problem in the
courses so we're working on that we have
an internship program and the employer
supervisor fills out a form and I also
go and meet with them and we ask them
how well prepared where are students in
terms of technology when they came in
are you satisfied and most importantly
is there anything we can do to prepare
them better and we've gotten some really
good feedback because we send a lot of
kids to grad school but we a lot of our
students become actuaries and they go
into the business world and in in those
worlds like excel vba rules I mean it
does even though most academics don't
see it as being that important it's out
there I did talk really fast but where
are we we've come a long way I'm still
bitter about that proof writing course
that the technology was taking but you
know I patience is a virtue and I'm
sneaking it back in and hopefully we get
it back in there so I'm gonna stop here
because we're basically out of time any
questions yeah
yeah the proof riding course is a
sophomore course I I'll give you my card
and I'll send you and the computational
math class is another baby I mean I'm
trying to get a book out of that one so
I've written a ball I don't you I wrote
up my own notes and I'm Paul I'm taking
a sabbatical in the spring to write that
up but I'll give you my card and there's
a there's also a meaning a meat group
tomorrow for math educators so maybe we
could hook up there if anyone else is
interested so I think we are out of time
right beyond time almost thanks
[Applause]